Transcription: Regis Feve
Relecteur: eric vautier
Ce soir, je vais vous parler de
comment l’art stimule la confiance.
Alors je vais essayer de pas vous
faire un discours trop...
« Je me la pète », « L’art contemporain »,
« La culture est un bien essentiel ».
Je suis comme la plupart
d’entre vous dans cette salle.
Je ne ressens pas grand-chose
quand je suis devant un tableau
« Carré blanc sur un mur blanc ».
Mais,
moi, ma première
grande émotion artistique,
je l’ai eue en jouant à Indiana Jones.
En 1995,
je suis une jeune égyptologue qui
fouille sur le site de Saqqarah.
Un matin,
avec plusieurs autres archéologues,
on se faufile à travers un trou
pour entrer dans une cavité
qui est remplie de sable.
En déblayant le sable de cette cavité,
on met au jour une paroi.
Cette paroi, elle est gravée, sculptée.
Elle représente une femme, assise.
Sur ses genoux, elle tient un enfant.
A côté de cet enfant,
il y a une inscription royale,
Toutankhamon.
J’assiste à la découverte de la tombe
de la nourrice de Toutankhamon.
É - norme !
Je suis tellement émue, je pleure.
J’aimerais tellement
que vous puissiez ressentir
ce que j’ai ressenti à ce moment-là.
Les poils qui se dressent, les papillons,
ça me donne une telle énergie positive
que j'ai envie de percer tous les mystères
des civilisations antiques.
Bon, la suite de l’histoire
est un peu moins glamour...
Le milieu de l’archéologie est carrément
trop étriqué pour moi. Dont acte.
Je voudrais qu’on revienne à ce fameux
tableau blanc sur mur blanc.
J’ai une question à vous poser :
pourquoi est-ce qu’on les met
dans les musées ?
Pourquoi est-ce que vous payez
pour aller les voir ?
Et pourquoi vous avez
suffisamment confiance
pour en parler ou même dire
que vous ne la comprenez pas ?
C’est surprenant
quand même ce qu’une œuvre...
ce que l’art...
vous fait...
vous fait ressentir.
Et alors, imaginez juste un instant
le pouvoir d’une œuvre
qui vous bouleverse.
Bon, alors moi, en ce moment,
ce que j’aime, ce qui me touche,
ce sont les artistes qui s’intéressent
à notre monde contemporain.
Par exemple, les œuvres qui décryptent
des sujets de société,
des sujets d’actualité comme...
je ne sais pas... euh...
le mouvement #MeToo, les J.O.,
le réchauffement climatique
ou encore les fake news.
Prenons les fake news.
Ce mouvement qui a mis à mal
notre confiance en les médias.
C’est quand même fou.
Se dire qu’aujourd’hui,
les journalistes sont obligés
de justifier de leur intégrité.
Est-ce que ça n’a pas fait
complètement basculer
et changer nos façons à nous
de communiquer,
de nous informer ?
Je vous entends déjà vous dire :
« Qu’est-ce qu’elle veut faire
avec les œuvres d’art ?
Déjà qu’on n’arrive pas à démêler
le faux du vrai
avec les scientifiques et les experts.
Que peuvent les œuvres d’art
pour nous aider à aiguiser
notre esprit critique,
à mieux comprendre
ce que sont les fake news ? »
Alors, je vous propose d'essayer.
Commençons par un premier sujet
qui est la censure.
Si je vous dis « le petit oiseau bleu »,
vous pensez au symbole du réseau Twitter,
ce réseau très influent d’Internet ?
Celui qu’on pointe du doigt
pour son incapacité à enrayer
le flot de plus en plus important
des fausses informations,
voire plus grave,
des informations
intentionnellement mensongères
ou carrément haineuses ?
Que pouvons-nous faire ?
Là, derrière, vous avez une œuvre.
C’est une installation monumentale
d’un artiste
qui se fait appeler EncoreuneSTP
qui vient du monde du street art.
L’artiste a mis en cage
douze petits oiseaux.
Pour nous interroger un peu
sur cette dérive informationnelle,
il a fixé sur chacune de ces têtes
des petits messages complètement absurdes.
Comme par exemple « Le gouvernement
désormais taxera les bénéfices du doute. »
Ou encore, « Au permis de conduire,
dorénavant, l’examen
inclura les insultes aux cyclistes. »
Alors, qui est dans cette cage ?
C’est l’artiste avec ses fake news ?
C’est vous ?
C’est moi ?
Avons-nous bien mesuré
l’impact de mettre notre liberté
d’expression dans une cage ?
Alors ici, l’artiste,
il nous interroge
et il nous met face à un paradoxe.
Notre liberté d’expression,
c’est un droit fondamental
de toutes les démocraties.
On a toujours lutté
et nous luttons aujourd’hui
pour cette liberté d’expression.
Alors, est-ce que la censure,
qui est quand même
un outil de prédilection des dictatures,
pourrait être aujourd’hui
un outil, une solution
qui nous permettrait
d’avoir de nouveau confiance
dans les réseaux et dans les médias ?
Je vous laisse y réfléchir.
Je vous propose de passer
maintenant sur un autre sujet.
Le sujet de l’emprise.
Qui a l’impression
que les GAFA ont tout pouvoir
sur nos vies ?
Qu’ils nous espionnent ?
Est-ce que -
Est-ce que les GAFA, par exemple,
volent nos données
pour avoir encore plus
d’emprise sur nous ?
En 2018, un jeune artiste berlinois,
Simon Weckert,
va avec des copains à un concert.
Le groupe entier, tous,
ont ouvert leur application Google Maps
pour se diriger.
Ils marchent dans une petite rue de Berlin
et d’un coup,
l’application leur dit :
« Il faut changer d’itinéraire.
Il y a un embouteillage. »
Mais il n’y a pas de voiture.
En fait, malgré eux, ils ont créé
un embouteillage virtuel
parce que Google Maps
ne fait pas la différence
entre un piéton
et un conducteur de voiture.
Ici, derrière moi, vous avez
une capture d’écran de cette vidéo
que l’artiste va réaliser
suite à cette expérience.
Il va demander à un figurant
de se promener dans les rues de Berlin
en tirant un chariot rouge
dans lequel il va mettre 99 portables
qui sont connectés à Google Maps.
Il va créer un embouteillage virtuel
parce que l’application
va dire aux automobilistes :
« Changez d’itinéraire. »
Cette vidéo, qu’il a appelée
« Google Maps Hacks »,
a été postée sur YouTube.
En quelques heures, elle a fait
plus de 3 millions de vues.
Et en l’espace de quelque temps,
quelques internautes justement
se sont demandé
si ce n’était pas une fake news.
Si les GAFA sont
effectivement tout-puissants,
ils ne sont pas infaillibles.
Et nous aussi, nous pouvons
avoir une emprise sur eux
et les piéger.
Je continue sur une troisième idée
qui est la manipulation.
Regardez cette photo.
Connaissez-vous cet endroit ?
Y êtes-vous allé ?
C’est en Islande ? En Nouvelle-Zélande ?
En fait, non.
Cette image n'existe pas.
Ce paysage n'existe pas.
Cette œuvre, ce paysage,
il a été créé grâce à une collaboration
entre un artiste catalan,
Joan Fontcuberta,
et un laboratoire de recherche
qui étudie les mouvements
de l’écorce terrestre
qui permettent la formation des montagnes.
C’est méga sérieux, quoi.
En échangeant avec ces chercheurs,
en comprenant qu’ils utilisent
des logiciels assez poussés,
dont un, Terra Gen, qui permet
de reconstituer des paysages,
l’artiste a l’idée d’intégrer
dans le logiciel un tableau.
Ici, c’est le tableau « Le rêve »
du Douanier Rousseau.
Ce tableau représente
une femme nue allongée,
dans un paysage verdoyant très luxuriant.
Ne cherchez pas la femme nue,
elle a complètement disparu
dans le logiciel
qui l’a transformée dans ce paysage.
Par cette œuvre, l’artiste nous interroge
sur les mécanismes de crédulité
que les gens peuvent avoir
face aux images.
Qu’est-ce qui fait qu’on va croire
qu’une image est vraie ?
Qu’est-ce qui fait qu’on va la retenir ?
Est-ce que c’est parce qu’elle est belle ?
Parce qu’elle nous réconforte ?
Parce que c’est facile ?
Moi, je fais un autre parallèle
avec cette photo.
Ce sont les photos
que nous postons des paysages
lorsque nous voyageons,
lors de nos vacances.
Est-ce que sincèrement
ce n’est pas un peu une course
à l’échalote de la plus jolie photo,
de là où il faut se mettre
pour être sûr qu’il n’y a personne dessus.
Oui parce que je sais que si on se met là,
on aura un plus beau point de vue.
Mais est-ce que ça reflète la réalité ?
Est-ce qu’on n’est pas en train
d’inventer aussi nos vies ?
Et alors, j’ai envie de vous poser
la question : « Qui manipule qui ? »
Est-ce qu’on n’est pas tous un petit peu
des petits manipulateurs en herbe ?
Ces trois œuvres,
pour moi,
elles illustrent et elles démontrent
qu’en fait, des artistes
peuvent nous interroger,
peuvent nous donner
une autre façon de regarder les fake news
et peut-être aiguiser un peu
notre esprit critique
et ne pas prendre les choses
comme elles viennent,
tout simplement parce que c’est un expert,
parce que c’est un scientifique,
parce que c’est notre voisin
qui nous l’a dit.
Et moi, j’en retiens au moins
trois messages, de ces œuvres.
Le premier message, j’ai envie
de me dire : restons critiques.
On ne va pas arrêter d’utiliser Internet,
il est clair.
Et puis, on peut se le dire,
on a tous le réflexe d’inviter
notre téléphone portable dans nos dîners,
dans nos réunions de famille,
dans nos réunions de travail,
quand on cherche un restaurant.
Alors, si les GAFA sont
effectivement très puissants
et qu’ils nous permettent de
trouver les informations qu’on cherche,
il n’empêche que l’on doit
rester prudent, vigilant
et critique sur ce que l’on dit.
Deuxième message.
Peut-être que nous pourrions arrêter
de travestir nos vacances et nos voyages.
Évidemment, nous n’allons pas arrêter
de prendre des photos, mais,
ces photos que nous postons,
elles participent à nous endormir.
A nous faire accepter la fausse image
comme une vraie image,
parce que ce que nous postons
n’est pas vrai.
Alors si on a appris, on peut se le dire,
à faire plus attention
aux aliments que nous mangeons,
Si nous avons appris
à trier nos poubelles,
peut-être que maintenant nous pourrions
arrêter de travestir nos vies,
et d’être peut-être un peu plus vrai
sur ce que nous postons,
d’être peut-être plus responsable.
Troisième message.
Peut-être pouvons-nous résister
à la paresse intellectuelle,
à la facilité intellectuelle.
On est d’accord, on ne va pas arrêter
de demander aux instances politiques
de mettre en place
des démarches pour enrayer
les fake news, bien évidemment.
Mais -
J’ai un trou.
(Encouragements et applaudissements)
Mais choisir la censure est un leurre
au service d'une autre propagande.
Je pense qu’on ne peut pas
éteindre le feu par le feu.
Si on partageait peut-être avec un peu
plus de parcimonie les informations,
si on ne cliquait pas aussi facilement,
peut-être que dans ces cas-là,
on permettrait aux informations
de circuler un peu moins vite.
Et si elles circulaient un peu moins vite,
peut-être qu’aussi les fausses
informations circuleraient moins vite.
Alors pour conclure,
j’ai envie de vous dire :
« Allez dans les expositions,
allez voir des pièces de théâtre,
allez au cinéma, allez écouter un concert,
allez voir un spectacle de cirque »
parce que peut-être qu’un jour,
vous allez passer devant un tableau blanc
sur fond blanc, que vous penserez à moi
et que vous vous rappellerez
que je vous ai dit :
« Ayez confiance dans vos émotions »
parce qu’elles sont vraies,
et ça, c’est précieux.
(Applaudissements)